this is a Cyrus Ranger and this thing is
a beast
[Music]
now we've tested multiple e-bikes but
nothing like this one now there are many
things that set the ranger apart the
first one is the full suspension we have
the suspension here on the front but
what a lot of e-bikes don't have is rear
suspension and this is a multi-link air
suspension that has a lot of
adjustability and it does a killer job
when you're mountain biking or going
over rougher terrain now with that it
has a 750 watt Hub motor that goes up to
1200 Peak wattage so you have a lot of
power and this thing can hit 20 miles
per hour using the throttle alone but if
you're pedaling with it I've hit 30 and
I could go even faster not that you need
to now what is really special is that
unlike most e-bikes this thing has a
torque sensor which means that it
doesn't just go faster the faster you
pedal but if you pedal harder it senses
that torque and it'll actually speed you
up which is really really nice now what
powers the motor is a 20 amp hour 52
volt battery that is stored inside the
frame right here you have a key to lock
it and unlock it so you can remove it to
charge and it's interesting that's a 52
volt system it has better quality
batteries than a lot of other e-bikes
then you can actually get 56 miles of
range when you're pedaling in a lower
assistant mode but even if you're
cranking it going fast you still have
great range now on the front here
another thing that stands out is that it
has hydraulic brakes instead of regular
cable it has hydraulics that go through
that makes it a lot better and on the
front we have a large disc brake and the
same thing on the back so it's way more
reliable than other less expensive
systems now the tires are four inch fat
tires they're large they have a ton of
grip which is great for trail riding
like we are doing today so you have a
ton of stability you don't have to worry
about losing traction it works out
really nice and because you have the
electric assist it's not hard to ride
with those large tires now it has a
Shimano nine gear system right here so
you can change your gears the levers are
set up very conveniently as well where
you have a back lever to switch that
also makes it easier and with that some
of the accessories are really nice we
have the headlamp in the front 250
lumens nice and bright to make sure that
you're seen on the back here the seat is
super comfortable way better than a nice
brand non-e-bike for a mountain bike
that I have so this is nice lot
adjustability and then on the back the
kickstand is also super durable unlike
some other e-bikes that we have tested
to be honest I was really surprised by
how high quality all of the accessories
are not just the seat in the kickstand
the grips the controls everything is
really really nice including this large
display where most e-bikes have small
vertical displays this gives you a lot
of information so you can see exactly
what is going on and overall the bike is
impressively high quality of course you
have your mounts right here if you want
to put a water bottle holder on there
and if you look at the reviews both on
Amazon on their website on other
websites their views are really really
good people are loving these things
loving the quality the durability it
just does a great job so you guys can
find a link in the description but
enough talking let's go ahead and do
some writing now I really enjoy mountain
biking but it's always been a pain
because you spend most of your time
trying to get up the hill first for
example I want my son took us a half
hour to get up the hill and then five
minutes getting down you're extremely
tired you're hot you're sweaty and even
though it's enjoyable it's a good
exercise you don't really want to go out
as often as you should because of that
at least for me
so having an e-bike that can also handle
mountain biking is awesome because I'm
going out in nature way more often I
really like the gear system because
right now I am using pedaling and not
the throttle
we're going up this pretty steep hill I
don't know if you guys could tell and
just dropping it down a couple gears
definitely makes it easier now the
terrain here has rocks some gravel some
spots where water went down and the
tires are having no issues handling all
of this oh that's so much better with
the electric assist
we have all these rocks
not a problem with that suspension nice
and smooth
as you guys can hear I'm still getting
some good exercise I still feel it in my
legs
I'm not just being lazy and just using
the electric but I also don't have to
stop five six times going up a big hill
to get rest like I did a couple weeks
ago and I went out with my son
oh the scenery is beautiful out there
you guys see Vadim he has a white
version here we're testing out the
bricks
really good control
I don't have to press very hard to get
enough braking power ah this is so
awesome
the grip is nice I can actually break
pretty hard without losing traction
because those fat tires
yeah that's what makes a mountain biking
so fun can't believe we made it up here
so quickly
without getting tired
and right now we're hauling
25 miles an hour
but it's very stable
oh yeah you guys see vadim's air
suspension working
[Music]
whoa Bridge
it's crazy how much the throttle could
just do by itself
I also really like that if I'm using the
throttle it doesn't just kick in a ton
of power right away has an algorithm
where it Smooths in the power
let's keep going and we'll see what you
think about it so I've been riding this
thing for about over a week and we're
mountain biking up here now which is
absolute blast I like I can't believe
the suspension's working so well the air
suspension in the back like I'm shocked
that I didn't fall it's just amazing but
I've been riding a little bit with my
wife my kids on Centennial Trail here in
Spokane
on the asphalt super smooth super fast
her e-bike only goes up to 20 so it's
nice this one you could go up to 28 and
if you pedal harder you could go even
faster but that's already crazy fast I
also went with my family
on a nice little bike ride was about 22
miles in total this thing was amazing
the Comfort the seat I really like the
seat there's lots of bikes that have
these heavy seats and they just suck
this is super comfy
like look at this like this thing's
handling with ease while I'm talking
I could just go down here
this thing is amazing back to Max here I
actually ended up switching it to the
pass number three there's five different
controls for the pedal assist and the
five had so much power that it didn't
even need it so going to three is
excellent
and so I'm getting a good amount of
exercise on my Apple watch
and so this is fun fast and still good
for you all right here I can get some
more speed
let's get cranking let me kick it up to
five okay that's work sensor kicking up
oh my goodness I'm hauling it I would
never be able to do something like this
on my regular
mountain bike
cruising 22 right now 24 25 yeah let's
slow down a little bit
oh
oh my goodness okay this is a sweet
Trail
it's kick back
pet a little bit more
oh man
I don't know if you guys could tell the
speed here
cruising 23 miles an hour
down this Trail
I'm confident because the tires are so
grippy
oh hidden those rocks there okay slow
down oh that was awesome
you gotta get outside and do some fun
stuff
not just be inside playing with tech
all day every day
[Music]
I hope the camera is okay
so we did have a casualty
my insta 360 stick snapped in half
hitting that tree we still got the
footage
so just be careful here
turn down the power a bit
we'll head back
to the truck
that was awesome
so that was a ton of fun Vadim last
what's your battery life at 71 pretty
good I was doing a lot of throttle only
like over here up there yeah you went
far over here on the trails when you got
those drone shots pretty impressive and
you said um you did a good ride 71 are
you closed out your activity ring I did
so we still got a good workout mine has
a ton of battery but I rode less I was
using less throttle a lot more pedaling
and actually use a lot of level three
and level two oh nice assist instead of
keeping level five because dude has so
much power in it yeah has a ton of power
where there you guys go you guys can go
check out their website we have the link
down in the description this thing is
higher end it's not anywhere near as
expensive as some of the other
um e-bikes are set up for Mountain so
when you factor in all of the features
the torque sensor full suspension
um and then the hydraulic brakes the
price tag is a really good deal for what
you get so if you're interested go check
it out click that Circle above to
subscribe subscribe check out one of
those other videos right over there it's
been Maxine and Vadim and we'll see you
in the next one